freddie peralta yeah making his first
start since august 18th it was at st
louis only two innings has some shoulder
tightness but the opposition is hitting
150 against him that's best in the major
leagues
and when i walk good take
swing out of this peralta strikes out
o'neal out number two there's nolan
arnado 27 home runs now
and he is driven in 85.
nolan hits it a ton out to deep left
yelich back at the wall two nothing st
louis
a nolan oronato bomb and home run number
28. cardinals on top two nothing and
tonight adam wainwright yadier molina
will make history as the starting
battery for the cardinals for the 300th
time anywhere between what 69 miles an
hour and 74 for that curveball
and then he's got a slider too and
that's what he gets adamus with right
there
struck him out first k for wainwright
here's a chopper to the first baseman
goldsmith underhands to wayne right
three up three down onto the second two
nothing cardinals
that crazed molina and he's hit by the
pitch
that's outside so he's and now
a walk and the first two have reached
here in the top of the second
the one two
hit up the middle base head
the bases will be loaded now for adam
wainwright sixth or seventh inning when
they start to bring in all their good
guys base head into left off the bat of
adam wainwright
battery mates for the 300th time and
look who brings in yachty it's adam
wainwright tommy edmond very good
numbers with the bases loaded and the
first pitch to him
hits softly towards short
out there the turn not in time and a run
does score to make it four nothing as
edmond scoots down the line now you just
got to see some pitches
then he lays the bat on one here dumps
one into left field nothing to it
lined
on a hop edmond and a double play 4-6-3
on the double play they're not a homart
in the first inning
and nolan hits it out to deep left
center goodbye
his second home run tonight wow what a
bad pitch right there nolan oronato with
home run number 29
and he's driven in three tonight and the
cardinals add on it's five nothing st
louis
[Applause]
and that's a base hit to left
topo is a little slinger
and sosa
pops it into shallow right aureus can't
get there drops in for a hit dylan
carlson to
second base
there's bader and a single div center
with runners at first and second back in
the second inning one two pitch
and bader sends it out to deep left
yelling's back gone
it's a home run
three run homer
vader
and the cardinals
now an eight run lead
here in the top of the third
here's a hard hit ball to the right side
tommy edmond dives makes the play comes
up and throws him out
nicely done by tommy edmond who's made a
couple of nice plays in this game so i
mean it's truly historic what he's doing
3-2 pitch
inside corner and struck him out
and that's three tonight for adam
wainwright might be a little payback
right there
ground ball to the right side and that's
handled by goldschmidt underhand flip to
wainwright covering and escobar is uh
quietly retired just a little bit of bad
stuff and then swinging a bouncer hit to
left base hit
for urias
there's your ground ball there's double
clay
that'll go six five
no three
a lead at first base for roddy teles
kane swings and misses he's out on
strikes he went for a pitch down and
away and couldn't hold up pats on the
back all smiles he looks over and it's
all happy until christian yellett says
something
and
gibson throws him out
and there he goes he's out of the game
anyway so i guess why not take that
ejection and that fine
and he lost him ashby is aboard
3-2 pitch
bueno lets it go wisely and it turns
into a double play
goldie here then o'neill and arnotto
that pitch taken outside so the
cardinals have their first base runner
against ashby a tough night for tyler
o'neill over three three strikeouts
and o'neill
makes up for it with a long one right
center
adios wow number 22 for tyler o'neill
he looked lost
but not anymore two runs shot and
another st louis home run
sosa
and got gotta want to play
under the glove of nolan aronado and the
concentration there by edmundo soso nice
play
not how they draw it up but what a play
is right
there's a soft lighter and that's down a
base hit avaya is with a single in the
right center
after the first six weeks so hits it
sharply up the knee and into the
outfield of
sosa
and with a 10-run deficit jason lane
wisely
holds escobar the bases are loaded
it's mcfarland into the ball game
see if riley telez can change that on
the first pitch bouncing ball edmond
makes the play oh it's dropped
everybody's safe and a run is in
and here is lorenzo kane
kane on the ground sosa's got it throw
to third and arnado gets a toe on the
back yeah bowling play he had a good
play by aaron to get back to the bag
yada year molina hit by a pitch and
scored fly to center grounded to short
and fly to right high fly ball
lifted into deep left at the wall gone
it's a grand slam
on the night in which yachty and bueno
make their 300th appearance together as
battery mates
bueno's about to win
yeti's gone deep with a grand slam
[Applause]